Wilbur theater the New Year's Eve Bryan
Callen the new years of naive I'm doing
me receive at the Wilbur
nice dude how excited Road Dogg back on
tour this week
Dallas probably can find me at the pecan
lounge in the barbecue when I'm not
there Thursday Friday Saturday night I'm
at the Addison improv Dallas this
Thursday through Friday next week Salt
Lake City wise guys get your tickets t
fat k calm just announced
shavon friends night before Thanksgiving
Ice House Pasadena Kalyn will be there I
will be there other special guests will
be there one night one show only that is
November 27th tickets at T fat K calm
get your tickets now coming in hot on a
Monday I want to go coming in hot on a
Monday I'm gonna label this Monday how
about those ice cubes oh dude final meal
will you get your coffee open open open
him hourly I get to funnel milk coffee
and they go I'm they open for daddy I'm
like oh yeah they opened for me I go
what time do you guys open normally cuz
it's the Veterans Day and he goes nine I
go but the morning rush she does not
it's not us you come in they don't want
to rush it no you take your time with
our coffee you get a coffee we got to go
have a regular ushe we have to go we
have the the coffee look that they make
in the [ __ ] beaker that oh you're
talking about the funnel yeah well it's
called funnel man I guess it's fun yeah
it's a funnel I guess it's a funnel
beaker the beaker looks a speaker looks
like they're in a lab you take your time
you like the ambience in there well I've
told him I told him I said I said they
got out they gotta fix the ambience a
little bit it's very like in this in a
racially it's very light remember is
very minimalist in a very minimus neighs
we were only feel that fun food yes yes
first by a cute 3d that's how it is but
they I told him II I said I said you
should if you got somebody who was
really hip to do like a guy like court
to get in there and mess around a place
it'd be it'd be huge think restoration
what I do think Restoration Hardware
with a dash of Big Trouble in Little
China there's a good call right there
yeah that's a that's a very good call
[ __ ] tell them now and I want free
coffee for life you are for life I want
actually want five I would owe my master
the business
right let's go in there let's renovate
and get five percent but they take so
long you a copy but it's so good man no
they don't
it's just there's no rush there's not
you're not rushing them I know but
money's you know time is money
mm-hmm mm-hmm they're an expensive part
of town - oh yeah yeah they're a long
time they don't care now how's dinner
white team now they're no wife team are
they husband a to evade to offer me a
disaster no they've been been together
for 20 years I'm really oh yeah the
business is way out though you know keep
being a B Nia when he came in dude well
its first of all it's early yeah daddy
has to shoot so you made me come in
early daddy yes shoot you got shoes got
shadows your dad she could have shot at
1:30 but daddy said to himself I know
how well it's a [ __ ] show it's too
late for Papa Bear and I know how this
show goes custom as we move slow and
then it gets too crazy it makes daddy
crazy here's the thing yeah you think a
B if they be through right yeah you
think a B C now be cool okay I'll be
cool you think a B C gives a [ __ ] about
your podcast and they probably don't mmm
they probably don't but my producers too
mmm
you know I go there's a problem yeah
there's a problem they don't they don't
they like what they don't care yeah no
it's just no no it's 2 million dollars
an episode yeah think you out there I
embrace my ax like what your pluck your
your little podcast you don't realize
what a podcast is they don't feel it's
very strange it's very weird and you
know and especially on a day like we do
a Monday we wake up early oh and and you
know it's a Bob - Bob them in the
[ __ ] Monday right it's a bottom in
the [ __ ] Monday wait little bit in
the [ __ ] sometimes you got a bottom in
the [ __ ] you know what I mean now you
can say you up clean the room Monday
that's CIA that's crazy because I prefer
clean the room clean the room Friday
because they've had a long time that's
been a long week then you're dead clean
it up yeah it's a it's a gamey rim it's
a game days yeah let's clean the room
Friday's for people you really hate
sometimes when I'm in the [ __ ] on
Monday to wake them up hey we got a week
ahead of us now now going on in South
got a Boppy in the [ __ ] you
understand now let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question brother of
mine
you let my best friend in a lot of ways
my
true I mean we would iron clothes it
runs deep like I'd do some [ __ ] for you
help you I help you hi dab on some [ __ ]
together
yeah I hope you hide a body punch them
in the the one guy you can rely on I
mean the dog right I mean where you
going with this
well when the chase you're do down well
yeah whatever you besides money no
question as friends what's the statute
of limitations on a gal like let's say
you we go as deep as we do let's say the
river runs as deep as it does it sways
you and I you know understand how we cut
through the grand oh yeah yeah we cut
through the [ __ ] Grand Canyon
Brotherhood now we're like the Nile yeah
now you've had women in your life I've
had women in my life oh no I'm saying I
know you're going in there Joe do you
want what's up what's it what's it look
like oh man you wanna that's problem
everything no no that's forever I can
swing your still that's the mama chilled
now listen listen no no I misread listen
you misread the situation but at what
point when you've dated somebody does
the statute of limitations wear off and
your boy can feel around Bop min shader
did you meet a friend of mine you want a
Bopper in the [ __ ] I'll ask I put that a
question I'm asking a hypothetical
question can i or can't I have to know
who it is how long we dated dated for a
while you're all crazy about it and you
ran into her huh yeah now did she
recognize you or did you see her and
scope her out well I saw her first I was
with my children my offspring okay I
went that's a hot looking woman and dad
even though he's with kids got creepy I
said hey kids look at the menu and don't
take your eyes off the menu until my
daddy got scanner
daddy daddy let's get hey kid you know
the routine daddy's gonna scan now I
said in front of my kids I go I'd like
to bop her and there sugar
the kids we had a cry I go grow up
they seem I'll bop it [ __ ] right now
and then and then no this person said hi
to me and I was like hi I think I know
you've recognized rut then she
introduced herself to my boy
Adam Rodriguez who came in and I went oh
you're eating with adam no adam came in
with this beautiful fan at least there
came yeah I was scared and and I want
that place is just one that place is one
big it's just where you scanned
yeah it's scanners it's just one
good-looking human being after another
scanners men and women peepers but I was
kidding hey hey no keep always like me
obviously we're on you like a [ __ ]
from the way less steep ooh you're
getting heat from the old acting
erratically relax brother
why is your breathing changing it's not
dude I'm pretty calm all right pretty
calm right now
yeah hey what is it what's the statute
of limitation I mean dude when does the
light turn green when's it egg when's it
again when can I pop em in yeah now you
can do that yeah I can do that all right
what is the statute of limitation though
I that's a good that's a good question
cuz I've had friends who've who've I had
a friend and her girl his girl was
calling me sending me texts and I was
like and I would never cuz you just
don't it's just too complicated it
depends but I would call a buddy just
like but the guy was like done he had
other and I was like lemme and he'd be
like no I go come on
but you learn want it to I mean I
watched she was you would attend sure
yeah if your buddy was like in a
straight relationship with him even then
I don't know I don't know if I'd care
well I wouldn't you and I are probably
not as you know especially have enough
time good [ __ ] what are you talking
about you know if you like bringing
around [ __ ] that'd be weird
well you gotta if you if it's five years
four years I mean go ahead yeah you're
talking about I don't care a train but
at the end of the day sometimes it can
get some people are weird little dicey I
don't think you're weird like
ah I don't know we don't wanna die cut
haven't there's so many chicks in the
world like you have to yeah chin it's
absolutely off limits for you huh hell
yeah completely off limits
well girls I'm the same way too I don't
mess around with anyone elses
ex-girlfriends I don't well that's a
very very good policy you know hot
believe me they've been super hot and
cute and pretty and all that stuff and
then eight and they're giving you
business you know do it big-time
business bro you don't tell you I'm not
that good okay it's just busting nuts
you know that's the rule but the problem
is it's I would never it's more goes
down to if I know the dude I'd have to
tell him cuz I don't wanna I don't want
him to call me on it I'd be so
embarrassed man I'd be so mortified
because I wouldn't be the guy say I am
so I'd be like you know I'd have to tell
I'd have to tell the guy I'd be pissed
if I let's say you did hook it with I'd
be pissed if you're like do you know who
I've been seeing blah blah blah
oh I'm not talking about seeing the
person know each other I'm talking about
it's Monday raw all right
it's Monday wrong monday wrong a little
puffy man pop McMuffin monday pile of
puffy I should've eaten pasta and had
wine last night I knew I wasn't even
that hungry face every time where'd you
eat it though Felix I still haven't been
there we'll go jewel well you got to go
off your key the pastas not going to
your ass huh you're losing your ass I
saw I noticed that this morning I said
that I know and now and I did it's a
good lunch it doesn't matter you
deadlift all the weight in the world
your ass is going as I'm everything to
get older yeah get that flat ass the mr.
burns ass that's true why is that look
that out so no it's gotta get is true
your nose grow and your ass leaves
yeah and I don't think your dick gets
bigger you know it doesn't start Charlie
dick is smaller over time real age 13 is
the small as it's gonna be age 2030 it's
all that hair for thirty but squat for
girls age of this is for chicks doesn't
count
same thing though right now they can
just inject fat in it guys really can't
I got to get on the old testosterone
once I get on TR t max it's good get a
[ __ ] you keep talking about it I know
you keep talking about I know how to
avoid old man flat bones why the older
people lose fat on there but just like
as we age ik you lose both muscle and
bone yeah that's just saying overall you
don't know what you do to kind of you
stay you make peace with the fact that
you're dying and disintegrating swell
yeah but with technology and with health
and fitness like we're so much more
educated than your parents yeah
yeah you know like you know what's
healthy what's not it's true about a
switchblade
why off the street cuz I'm 10 off the
street no I went to a gun shop and they
had these little and they they you can
always tell when they're this big but I
was like I want a little no daddy knows
we need the real ones you got it on you
know I was looking forward to show you
he goes yeah oh hi said one when I was a
kid yeah they're so cool yeah have that
a big boy though they got the stilettos
when they come out through the chute you
had the real one yes think it does a
good god they were cool yeah just in
case it's a situation should - there's
nothing cooler back in the old days that
guy would have a switchblade
that would be this lame mmm remember the
butterfly knife though guys oh well
let's just Filipino and headley Filipino
poor Holly those dudes are a bad
[ __ ] man
those guys who'd like that that's what
they do is trained in a knife fighting
yeah knife knives are so unforgiving
like but really you can only train a
knife fight if you're in Japan yeah and
if you're be a knife fighter attack
Filipino knife I mean I go [ __ ] is crazy
be a knife fighter in Texas you shot in
the face yes you getting shot but these
dudes are they do some crazy [ __ ] yeah
but also find another hobby though you
know yeah knife fighting is not good
also looks like your your hand to hand
combat stuff isn't gonna work but look
at that does be shot that dudes will be
shot of stab stab stare establish
depends on them what the bullet looks
like Hydra Shok power tip time I'll take
twenty-two over a [ __ ] huge place
these dudes are no it's it's [ __ ]
crazy oh wow look at them yeah those
guys are I think the same guy here yay
sweet star a child oh look at his face
the dead serious yeah he's done some
[ __ ] to you oh it's three of him though
yeah he'll open yeah but if I can't
fight through a triplets triplets are
hard to fight you know and I fighting to
a dying art look at that nice like a
curved blade those don't scare me they
the squiggly ones you know the squiggly
ones I think they had a picture it on
their chin yeah that top one nothing
gives me that yeah they're just pretty
unforgiving see you later
that thing is gonna you're gonna just
get [ __ ] it's gonna fall off yeah you
don't you don't hear a lot about knives
anymore the dying art dude well with
guns but neither not you know carrying a
knife in in California carry a knife
that's large enough it's a felony it's
not a misdemeanor a gun is a misdemeanor
a nice a night when they found it's like
a sword to frontier law anything over
two inches I believe is a felony yeah
it's a felony looks like young kid
there's a dude who's a camera guy my
thing and he had a straight up sheath
knife in a military sheath and the back
out of his belt in the back of his pants
right I was like right protection he
goes now just carry it for stuff I'll go
I don't think so that's a dagger sir
it's a dagger so you're either stabbing
people in their sleeper in their back
yeah under my bed I have this this large
knife I get from the military went to
that Marines thing they gave me this
knife for completing the mission mission
mission this big it's like what was like
command yeah yeah it's black yeah like
stainless steel yeah the best is going a
gun shop some of those guys are like
great and some of them are just I go
what's this knife for and a guy goes
survival well there's a giant sheath
knife I was like okay don't see sword
was shooting this weekend us shooting oh
I should do with my son
I wanted I want he's obsessed with my
guns and all that and I want to I want
to show him I want to give him respect
for gun he's obsessed with like the guns
off and I took a few but I took
to a firing range scared him right eight
years old and he was like holy [ __ ] you
tense he had this thing done he was ago
and at first he wanted to go I go I want
you to see what what guns do yeah I go
and I said every time you pull this
trigger somebody can die which means if
that happened to me I'd go away alright
so I gave him a really anybody shot at
22 rifle and it was Gregg's as no kick
and it was awesome and he's a really
good shot he gave him a desert eagle
legs
I came to Desert Eagle but I let him
hold I held on to a nine-millimeter I
put his hands around a nine-millimeter
and I and I and I said you pulled the
trigger but I held his hands that what
cop 7mm yes yeah and and I and I showed
him and he felt the kick it was this
Walter BB but he felt help cheese and
you only want to shout it shoot it twice
because I don't want to do this anymore
yeah I go okay so there you go now
that's power of a knife of a gun yeah so
it was a very good education then I had
the guy explained safety and where where
guns pointed all the time it was very
good his mother was really nervous about
it but I said let me let me just let me
just and I want it I want to educate him
at a young age so he knows what's up how
powerful and dangerous guns can be
because he could hear somebody was
shooting heavy caliber guns and he was
on fire so he it really became it took
them to sneak away from it it wasn't it
was no longer like pop pop out it was
like oh [ __ ] this is not a toy guns is
and I said so what do we learn he goes
respect for guns I go yeah and I go and
and how dangerous they are and
everything so his hold on I'm
nine-millimeter and now now I he's got a
loaded gun under his bed I said only
shoot this at him intruder yeah it's a
very good intent I believe in that I
believe in like just if a kid is
obsessed with something yes kill yeah
cuz I was I was that way I was oh [ __ ] I
was in I was obsessed I was like I want
to go I don't want guns I want like nerf
guns and super soakers whatever was like
I want what the cops shoot people with
yeah ever well I went to the gun store
and so he was like I like that I like he
was like whoa and he's holding them and
then I was like all right me that you
like might be a gang member
yeah all right now watch and we went and
then he did he naturally shoot to the
side like this yeah he's in the Hebrew
we jumped him into the gang
yeah we jumped him into the game I gave
my tattoo first tattoo easy on his face
yeah
anger crazy yeah I've never been that
into guns like a military family shut
the veterans Veterans Day you [ __ ] you
find try it by the way hey I can't
believe we didn't start this off that
way pop them in the [ __ ] Monday we
didn't say well today God bless the
veterans I know yeah happy Veterans
everybody for real and thank you for
your service god dammit no yeah we're
bad
well you're bad I've remembered well I
knew it was Veterans Day but we should
have taken a minute there's no traffic
is there yeah we should have taken a
minute to thank all the veterans and
thank you everybody do people get work
off for Veterans Day we're just talking
about that I don't know in LA listen and
now the special school might get that
you know they look for in excess take
the day off whatever it is mm-hmm
federal holiday so if you work at a bank
court gotta take a minute all bit all
banks are closed I would imagine the
regular business side I don't think it
is I remember when I was in Afghanistan
doing stand-up with dove and those guys
I remember some of those guys hadn't
seen their family in 15 months that's
insane you know you go through some [ __ ]
yeah difficult animals yeah yes really
long hours not sleeping at all ever
crazy [ __ ] not to mention people dying
yes the big one in it mm-hmm yeah I
don't think like regular offices are
closed today yeah it looks like it's
very much open in malls yeah Department
anything government owned their
libraries well my kids their library's
closed my kids go to public school so
there's nothing there so does that mean
they're closed yeah
as well they should be hey everybody
thank you for your service guys and gals
we appreciate it
all right that's the end of the podcast
if someone shouldn't you punch them in
the [ __ ] Friday night Monday bopping
the [ __ ] babam the speaking of Baba
man the [ __ ] what'd you do this
weekend besides Bop a lot of [ __ ]
no Friday at that food truck diary with
style bender mmm late though man we did
it like 4:30 he's a he's a veteran kid
fan yeah
oh yes awesome yeah it was that what was
that like he's such an interesting dude
yeah he's great
he's he's big man he's [ __ ] yeah I
was like he's as tall as you are
well the yeah yeah he might be telling
me my nature we might be the same height
but he's 6 for damn but when the rumors
about him and John Jones came about
fighting I was like you out your goddamn
mind yeah like he's too small for John
Joe you get wrestled to the no person
like oh oh no you could do it he goes
why do you think yeah mighty months we
want to fight him so he wants to fight
John Jones oh yeah
oh no he that's the plan he said 2021
they're gonna fight in Vegas so so what
are you that's a very intriguing idea I
feel like John Jones is just too much
too big for him I didn't say any but
when you see me in person yeah i can do
not cover now he's 208 accused yeah
Jesus Christ yeah you forget yeah he's
about it six four big and I was like you
big dude in his thinking his hands are
huge Wow but just a really really good
dude
smart smart man knife artists my Geryon
but Australian is he does they identify
more with being Nigerian or are
Australia well yeah he moved to Auckland
New Zealand New Zealand for a better his
family wanted to have a better educated
families very Nigerian though he strikes
me his way Mormon this is what's
interesting here is uh he just bought
this car he bought this in fear car guy
it's like a big boy car it's a it's a
720 s McLaren it's one of the fastest
cars in the world why is he's paying his
money on his gun on that right now I
guess he's a champion so [ __ ] it maybe
they gave it to him uh no he bought it
but he's he's I don't want Tabas
financial business but he's very smart
he's Nigerian okay Nigerian so here the
only money he here's the other thing get
well not all I mean no but there's a
channel well no no what I mean is by
Nigerian in Nigeria like he comes from a
large family
I I can guarantee that they are
generally pretty good with as a group
just depends yeah but the other thing is
is
yeah I didn't know he's a car guy but
buying a 720 s McLaren is pretty insane
cuz weird cuz I bought my new card on
Friday right about my new car oh you did
and I go you want to see some you get
what you were looking for I did Papa got
it the exact car the green man you're
such a man just agree moment nope I
didn't get the green one didn't get
Miami blue with red guts and and white
gold mouth that's so uh one of 60 that's
so you know you're something's gonna
drive you nuts now is it the fastest
Porsche ever made on earth is it the
fast production car in the world yes
Brian yeah I must you have that that's
where you that's what we're dealing what
I have to deal with all right there yep
that's it but the rims are white and red
God says in the inside there's red and
plaid it is so filthy it's so it's so
tell me it is so fast it is so [ __ ]
fast you know that you know what they
call this car why do they call it the
Widowmaker well you guys died in this
car well that's why I want let's go
ahead and be careful what is it why
don't drive crazy the [ __ ] Ferrari
what's amazing about you is that your
that's your primary car well this be my
daily driver that's your daily driver
yeah it's a racecar racecar now isn't
there this is crackage but isn't this
thing the word race car has to be opened
up and driven like a racecar for it not
to be in the shop all the time is that a
myth no not-not-not these my Porsche is
the ultimate so wait no so he's so
filthy so anyways so I found out Friday
that my guy found it and goes so that's
a voodoo blue on the left Miami blue on
the right and that's actually a gt3 RS
on the right gt2 RS on the left you
stupid [ __ ] so look at the exhaust for
God's sakes look at the width of the
back get the tires look at the in line
look at that look at the air vent damn
it look at
size of the wing okay well what would
keep it all down for you god that thing
is on amateurs it's awful oh you don't
know cars god you're gonna cut people's
heads off with that dumb fin oh it's
crazy anyway so I felt fright so I told
the guy went hey I'm sure I'm going to
Chicago and harass them all my guy Greg
who does all the cars for me I've been
harassed them all day hey dude I'm going
to shooting I Stratfor but if you find
this car cuz waiting to the car was the
semi SEMA auto show in Vegas because
this the guy who owned this billionaire
agent dude who owns it he got allocated
two of them a yellow one a blue one and
they're trying to get it out of this guy
to sell it to me it's brand new I was
like 60 miles under some [ __ ] great it's
insane
so I go and make this offer if he takes
it let me know he goes we'll see what
happens but it was a long shot
and so I'm just a get ready to shoot
with a style bender I have my phone on
vibrate and I never have my phone on me
ever
but swish when I'm shooting but then I
could feel it going off and I'm like God
sprite J or something like that
they kept going off like Oh daddy should
probably look Oh daddy God so I was
crunk about it so I told style Ben I'm
like dude I just got it I didn't know
he's car gay at all yo are you in the
cars you guys yeah and then I go dude
check this he goes that's crazy but luck
he was alright I just got a McLaren
720's which is comparable to Mike it is
on the truck he's a maniac - that thing
is but here's the thing he's not a huge
car guy
he showed me one of the reasons he got
it cuz he's really into anime and he was
look at the AI character and it's or
it's like this wolf thing I don't know
anime he's gonna keep it's like this I
hate a snarl Japanese or nine tails yeah
the ride are Japanese like a wolf that's
orange and black and the I was similar
to the McLaren
720s car she just look at it do you know
it oh you're not a car guy but the car
you bar here in anime sorry BOTS I I
mean it's like going from from a Casio
to uh it's like going from a dollar a
tiger as a pet I mean it's crazy what
what is that what is that what's that
run me if I want to if I want to dip my
toe into the car world and I want I want
to go right to the top
he's about
because you know there's not a ton of
those in New Zealand so there's the
markup in New Zealand's pretty crazy - I
would assume he paid around 400 at okay
the cool thing about these cars that
you're buying is that you get your money
back kind of though right you're kind of
driving if I'm right the McLaren not not
as much so as the Porsche that I bought
okay but he's gonna sign it for this
isn't a bad Buy at all
it's listen the cars you don't want
buyer like Lant Lamborghinis it
Lamborghini certain Ferraris you don't
want to buy a Sam Martin you don't want
to buy you don't want to buy that smart
cards that hold their value our Porsches
certain limited edition Ferraris do you
end out what what edit out the Aston
Martin thing why I doesn't matter
no it doesn't matter this is well
documented okay this isn't sorry you'd
have to edit that aren't all check it
out for fifty six thousand in New
Zealand yeah out there it's a different
you know different animal and a four
hundred and fifty six thousand okay I'm
pal I was so proud I got so Krunk laugh
family about a 720 then
this is besides my cousin Jason favorite
car gonna shut the [ __ ] up about
MacLaren's these things are demons do
you I would imagine you when if I know
how it's so loud if I spend almost half
a million dollars in a car I better
better have a [ __ ] machine I'm as
crazy as you can get your dick sucked in
this 100% now you know it comes with a
it comes with [ __ ] in your car um
yeah that's what people don't realize
you use a lot of money you're gonna get
you're gonna get you can be able to pop
a lot of [ __ ] and you're gonna be
able to get your dick sucked
now us proud of me got that but uh
provided the girl knows what the [ __ ] it
is that you thought they don't even need
to yeah you see like I'm a suck his dick
well that's a piece of art that is a
beautiful looking car it's cool it's
cool I can't drive a like you can't
drive on a regular road they cares any
in the road we can't drive on it I don't
know why there took your people over
look at how low sports cars are logo
everything is your Porsche that much yes
but it has a lift now let me ask you
this here's the thousand dollar question
your Ferrari did you get your money back
made about 2 grand you made money on it
so like I said so you throw like that's
an R for free yeah well you based kind
of certain Ferraris again certain fries
limited edition ones certain ones you
get your money back but that's crazy
because you drove you drove people high
drives for you drove that Ferrari for
free kind of yeah yeah how what did it
what total did it cost you you made two
grand on it overall yeah so you'll
remember this isn't just all me I get
that car guy Greg who this is so I
understand what I'm saying though is
that if you won't like if I was like all
let me get a I don't like a 48 a certain
like it's a certain Friday you like no
you're gonna lose your ass on that you
go if you if you want to buy a used one
and just [ __ ] around and keep it for a
while do that but if you you know depend
what you want to do you oh you only
wanna buy certain but is what I find
kind of fascinating about it is when you
spend that kind of money on a car that
people want and you go you you can turn
around and somebody is gonna buy it back
from you sometimes their markets
sometimes add as much money as you
bought it for more now remember to daddy
drives daddy drives us car now you're
gonna buy drive them so you wear my
shoes I Drive my cars I've seen it I
wear my shoes I Drive my car that was
your primary car those cars sit in
garages nah man you drive the [ __ ] out
of it and even though you drove that for
how long do you drive that Ferrari for
under a year under a year like drove it
every day so you have a you have a
problem now let me ask you this when you
are done where do we go from this car
where do we [ __ ] go well this one
it's such a collector's item you go on
it you want to pay this car off and then
start the collection you know I keep
this and then keep keep building for me
I sing that's the plan
you want a collection of cars oh yeah oh
oh yeah my buddy Kenny Griswold does
that now he showed me this crazy Ferrari
he's got money and he just he's he's
like you got to see this open his garage
I was like oh you do know huh it was a
white Ferrari he's one of the most
beautiful things I've ever seen in my
life yes certain ones are sick I was so
proud of style bender I was so proud of
Israel when he told me he kept out of
720's I'm like you son of a [ __ ] I'm
intrigued by this [ __ ] John Jones
[ __ ] I am too because when news broke I
was like I even told chin when he
brought
but I was like I'm not gonna entertain
that student this never happened
John Jones is too big you know just was
like it's so silly it's it's good for
them to talk about and then right when
Israel walked in I'm like holy [ __ ] dude
you're big guy I was like I sound like
Bryan Callen right now yeah I went
you're a big guy if people see me like
oh he really is big yeah and like now
the Jon Jones thing that seems so crazy
scene man we're like oh [ __ ] he's Syria
and he's that [ __ ] confident yeah he
has this similar trait that we've only
really seen with with Conor McGregor
where they say stuff and it actually
happens you know where they say stuff
and yeah where a lot of Fighters say
stuff and doesn't seem very organic or
natural when he speaks it kind of comes
to fruition and scaled he has a whole
whole plan you know you gotta remember -
he's 30
fighting green eyes he's been fighting
for it I'm not really footing but not
even that the point is is it's not like
you know he's this young kid who bought
a McLaren here's all the success he got
the UFC at the perfect time and he had a
lot of fights before that a lot of
fights before that and also you know
he's only been in the UFC for two years
mmm
two years world champion ah he's got to
fight uol no I knew what everyone's yeah
you always coming off the loss that's
right Paul Acosta was supposed to be but
Paulo's hurt so all right you know
there's Darren till there's there's
Romero either he's just very smart very
creative individual yeah just that mom
just checks all the boxes man as far as
to be a superstar yeah I told him on
camera that he's the that he's the
biggest star in the UFC I would agree
with that name can you name one bigger
can't John's definitely not no he's the
biggest right now for sure yeah I was
just one of the things that I was amazed
about with that with that Whitaker fight
there was a subtle thing that I saw that
that he was able to cut B right there
and he his
he's he's he was impossible to touch as
he was in the proximity of somebody
whose Lotus is that bigger still his
ability to kind of like move his face
just out of the way those little details
and stay in the pocket gets the 70
professional kickboxing fights yeah
there you go
so when you're going against these MMA
fights yeah much more advanced that's
what I mean and it's such a subtle thing
you like you're like you just can't you
can't get a clean shot on its face you
can't really burn all these other guys
it's it's gonna be tough for him to
match that that's always gonna be
champion for a long time because he is
that experienced in that background I
watched me and Roberto about the fights
this weekend with Greg Hardy it's just
like he did well but it's like what's
his ceiling well there's gonna become a
certain point where listen he fought
this vet he was never even close to
winning but he did get show up but it's
like is he ever gonna be a top-ten guy
no who are you talking Greg Hardy I
think in my hating on him no it's just
at his age and the the amount of a
football player yeah the amount of
experience that he lacks is just never
gonna strike in a work for him not just
not did you see the Logan Paul Kerr
fight did you see it yeah okay I won uh
he didn't though
he went off a technicality of shitty
judging but Logan Paul in that fight
how'd they look I mean they look
especially for not being fighters and
really only having one amateur fight
pretty [ __ ] good especially Logan
Paul athletically I cook you know to be
composed and stick behind a jab for the
first three rounds to where the guy I
was like a similar text like dude I'm
that's not easy to do especially selling
out staples son and not really swell you
know so many tickets as they did be on
that huge platform to be able to stay
calm and relaxed to stick behind a jab
for three rounds yeah you know
impressive that is with all that
pressure on you and praise watch I I
just think they kind of [ __ ] up
because they made they put two legit
legit fights on before I don't I don't
know why you just went to a hold YouTube
why cuz because they do comparing it or
something and no I just I feel like it's
just I know they they want a crossover
of the Billy Joe
Joe Saunders our [ __ ] I missed that yeah
Billy Joel he went yeah he didn't look
great but he gather done and then Devon
Haney's that you know the the youngest
biggest brightest star yeah coming up so
it just I think that was I would have
done that if I were them I would have
done more of a more of a youtuber
undercard they fought at 8 188
cruiserweight huh today I did I would
imagine Logan Paul had to suck down to
188 if that's what the cruiserweight is
no close your eyes thing damn there yeah
I couldn't ask ass I was like you guys
in just skin here's no it's over I'm not
no I'm good I don't know I don't wanna
be a box oh no no that's a lot of
training crews the winner is 200 pounds
okay who's interesting I really it gets
a lot of hate but it's like you know
crazy ass for two youtubers to I I
couldn't help but thinking about Canelo
fighting a Andre award coming out of
retirement
I wonder if that'll ever happen I wonder
if I were thinking about it well thanks
oh yeah he said no he said no yeah I
know yeah yeah I don't get why people
right really give I think the reason
people got says because they put on
these like legit world champion boxers
on this main card they're just done all
YouTube then no one really has you can't
really give anyone [ __ ] for it right and
also it's not like the zones a legit
boxing Network they're gonna be their
brand the brand new yeah but they have
no legacy there's no history there so
yeah you legit promoter and you know
I'll get my people care it's pretty
impressive these two youtubers they
could have done anything they can think
of done train the heart for it super are
legit trainers one train with Floyd
Mayweather's uncle oh really
God Roger Mayweather yeah entire camps
what who was who was in what was that
chaos IR is that its case
and then Logan Paul had the wheel
champion oh let's go champ
let's go champ Oh Berbick or a Trevor
Berbick Trevor Ross Christ
Trevor I mean Shannon Brandon breaks
yeah yeah sham break Stoney Jeffries
help them out
Wow legit camp huh yeah yeah look like
straight legit camp the other thing is
they did like countdowns for it
best countdowns you've ever seen for
leaning into a fight this is what they
do right there youtubers so the the cut
downs that they did build up this fight
I think they're both like 24 something I
mean if you're gonna do it you may as
well do it at that age why not at least
you can say you did it cuz that's a big
risk
that's a [ __ ] that's what I'm saying
like you gotta give them a little
respect cuz they get it knocked out
these two could have done anything they
could have done whose they could sprint
the climb mountains they need some jump
out of plant whatever it is now we're
good yeah they decided to box yeah which
is pretty [ __ ] they get along and in
real life are today they have this odd
they were actually hating each other but
you could even see afterwards guess I
was like because Logan's I came in I
know I talk a lot of [ __ ] you know I
hope it's over we're cool I shouldn't
built the fights the system personal
[ __ ] you see that case that ksi guy was
kind of like mmm he's like alright yeah
it's over man they were cool banging out
boys made some money I bet they did boys
made some money they did big boy money
too by far the highest paid on that card
well obviously though that's the only
reason everybody was there to see this
thing
it's impressive man yeah it opens up a
weird kind of portal now now you know
Eddie Hearns like I've been hit up by
all sorts of youtubers and celebrities
who want to do the same thing yeah you
do it just don't put on just don't have
the other legit fights underneath it mmm
I think that's where it gets dicey like
you're mixing the two worlds great and
these guys took it seriously too so it
was super I was in pretty close to
professional yeah good amateurs or no I
mean compared to Wyatt either what the
answer see like Golden Balls nah that's
stupid a different game
yeah different game yeah it's silly yeah
pretty impressive what they did though
yep
I don't but I don't feel like he's gonna
start too much of a trend cuz I don't
think too many youtubers want to Bob now
dude cuz you get hit once what happens
is you start training and you can't
punch like a sight that case I even up
or Sobers you up you see a you know the
fight
he's a sturdy kid that oh yes all
uppercut him [ __ ] wrong yeah
really dude are there any highlights
before I can't watch we probably can't
plan but there's definitely highlights
Rock them really oh dude
Wow Logan Paul got rock do you got that
down as well Jesus he did mm-hmm
no see this real quick yeah okay so that
guy just kept coming he looks so tired
too he knocks it down there him yeah the
uppercut was vicious and this is where
our Logan's at [ __ ] [ __ ] wrong oh
one DOJ's uppercut before but he had he
grabbed him by the head there I know but
the uppercut before it look at this oh
oh [ __ ] this is Ray J we lost two points
we grabbed the head you got to be in
shape
you got to be in [ __ ] that's crazy
this looks like a brawl that uppercut
was the best shot of the night he just
[ __ ] up cuz he gret he rocked them and
then grab that head and rock did you
tell me Logan wrestled in college or in
high school he's a big strong that's a
bold move
that's a beautiful move this is the the
grabbing your stuff like that's just
lack of experience how bad is that when
they do it if even it's just like
brushing across them but he did it's
just lack of experience he's not a bit
like it's this they don't leave ever
very tough to do that he's never he
looked very good that that slip and
uppercut is so hard to pull off I mean
that that itself is a big accomplishment
it's [ __ ] hard it's really hard to
box this way
look at him slip yeah look at him slip
he's just a he's a dad yeah I didn't
know that the problem is like this he
didn't need to grab that dude was
already [ __ ] up on that uppercut wow
there's a tough [ __ ] though if he would
have just not grabbed his head you know
and that but that's how Logan Paul cuz
they this wrath was
Dacus super outlandish the rest of a to
that checkpoints hmm which is unheard of
didn't warn especially these guys being
their first pro fight no warnings just
take two points away
they're both sturdy rough-looking his
man I mean they're guys I mean these are
strong as [ __ ] I mean big yeah hey look
good the rough was terrible though Graff
you took forever to break him up to the
rest loading tool I don't know what was
going on that ref the ref made about
himself is it yeah disappointing worst
case we don't take the points let's say
you took one point or a warning then
it'd be another draw yeah that was rough
looking those are that was the first one
yeah yeah that's interesting is the
interesting is entertaining as a way
better than I thought yeah like I was
like hey let's go the other fights that
just the production to zone was bad
where they're swinging I mean yeah I
think one mistake you're going sleep
there's [ __ ] guys like that hit hard
yes impressive they decided to do that
because again they could they could have
got however many views this I don't know
what the papery numbers are but how many
views it got they could have done that
doing playing chess these guys so fun
yeah they could done anything and
they're both done with it I don't know
if Logan is but Logan wants it back but
that guy said he's done yes Logan wants
to fight again because he feels like it
was taken from him the two points was
pretty freakin crazy
yeah I'm sure they're both pretty
concussed after that fight looks like oh
yeah they're not to be like a hundred
percent healthy for sure they're young
yeah yeah worth it
great yeah well I want to say I heard it
make 10 million dollars I think it was
more Justin Bieber was in the entourage
just off off the top I heard both made
10 and 10 did they give us fight person
numbers possibly
know what you're saying what the
commission pays them yeah Hebrew papers
were there making their money yeah
how much does it say Billy Joe Saunders
750 y'all getting ready to eat how much
is he here I think that's it all right
Marcella concerns you should grow up
this way or the other way others
Oh Devin Haney made a million dollars
that's nice that's a lot he house boys
making my nothing baby I'm curious to
see how many people bought it yeah I
think des owns making a little bit of a
mistake where they think there's gonna
be a crossover it's because the reason
they did they want subscribers to the
zone right but that young fan base they
don't I subscribe to the zone though
just because I they had the Canelo fight
and yes sir not what I'm talking about
so yeah so the reason why they did Logan
Paul Kerr thighs because they thought
the young kids would bring my
subscribers yeah I think they're off on
it
those kids are just gonna do that and
get out they're not into buying the
design Scott must have so much money
though because there's just they they're
getting they're guaranteeing these fires
so much money I thought they stopped
they started to pull back yeah yeah they
have to do it originally you know to get
all the big names yeah look and Paul's a
unique guy felt like a brick [ __ ]
big boy oh yeah oh yeah I don't really
know you know none of my friends really
watched it this no no I don't know any
of anyone like you Mike crew what they
don't watch it I'm gonna watch it yeah
I'm gonna start taking my training more
seriously I'll repeat it
what Whoopie go piss want me to help you
secure you secure your hips there you go
I'll ring your dick out call me when you
want it to be wrung out I'll wring it
out it's going now I'm not [ __ ]
keep this podcast going on my own listen
man I'm wearing right now look at these
underwear
look at these oh dude you got a ball
hammock yeah trim up a little though you
know hammock dude yeah yes I got the
nice perch for you Sam where am i I'm
wearing wearing my shyness tee underwear
my shyness tan to wear right now dude
and you got that ball hammock support
the design those look really cool dude
those look really cool yeah shows your
flat ass oh cool those are nice dude hey
you know it says bulge enhancing yeah
which yeah that's the ball hammock makes
your package look huge for real I got a
huge package dude and how about they
have a subscription which saves you 35%
and you get free shipping on every
single pair no commitments there's none
of that they're all I rest my is your
subscription choose your assortment
frequency they make sure you always have
a fresh pair of undies yeah they us got
NFL suits seamless bonds we got
hilarious
wow man hilarious dynasty for guys and
gals there are the best entourage that's
all I wear now yes and you guys can get
your first pair of subscription ball
hammocks for only 5 bucks right now just
head to shyness be calm
/h i n est Y shine ste dot-com slash
fighter get your first pair of ball
hammock boxers for only $5 your balls
your piece your route well thank you you
got to keep things trim you just told me
I just told you dude you just pulled
your pants down yeah I've got a bush
like the 70 now hold on my ball ass t my
de promise when it comes to your ball
area that's delicate area right no dude
you Nick your balls a thing please like
Ave it's a big problem I've done it
before you got it the route that's where
manscaped dot-com thank God they got
proprietary skin safe technology the
trimmer will not neck or snag your nuts
but you got to keep things tight and
respectful down redesign your electric
trimmer for specifically your nuts
Kian [ __ ] it's keep your nutsack as
clean and as well put together as a
Marines haircut Billy fade get it run
off free shipping today with the code
fighter at manscaped calm that's man s
CA PE decom promo code is back advisor
anti chafing Baldy or moisturizer come
on you type some up and free shipping
with the code fighter at manscape comm
that's 20% off with Free Shipping at
manscaped comm use code fighter yeah so
uh chin has friends that are there men
and their women other women yeah
organizing a group and just going down
and just giving out free hugs in Venice
they actually texted me hey you want to
come along now what are you going to do
that they want yo to be involved in the
hugging yes they're they're super they
volunteer for everything they're just
they're like that but I'm will do
something that's gonna make a difference
though I don't serve food for free or
and help bums out there you know bums do
you mean the homeless bums I love the
New York Times the liberal of New York
Times they're like it California's
homeless problem a lot of people have
lost their jobs because and now they're
on the street they not once not [ __ ]
once they mentioned that every one of
them that I've seen in Venice and on the
beach every one of them is a drug guy or
drunk yeah I mean what about that don't
talk to me will that work with them that
work with them you talk to cops you talk
they'll tell you that like in Seattle
the guy was like well there's he's in
there with them he's working with them
because the drug addiction is
essentially 100 percent what are you
[ __ ] talking about and that's one of
the reasons dream because like hey I'm
such a problem all their money went to
drug yeah but no cuz it's you know what
it is it's like they had a medical bill
they couldn't another on the street no
[ __ ] this is al this is a drug and
mental health issue yep for the most
part stop acting like it's not no they
did sick [ __ ] but you do with them
though give them hugs yeah what you do
is you create
shelters and they and you let the police
enforce the law which the police say you
can't be out here on the sidewalk you
got to go to a shelter do we have a
shelter each and more and I surrender
more and it looked like you're not
allowed you're not with all bums Prop 47
where is you're not allowed to move them
if they have a standing structure so if
they have a structure like that you
can't move them unless you have a place
to move them to and then property crime
becomes essentially unenforceable at a
certain so if they steal a bike you're
not gonna be able to really enforce it
so shop small businesses pay all the
[ __ ] they pay for this [ __ ]
sad all the way around it so why I don't
know I had a problem with it I don't
know what I got a problem with the fact
that you can just have this many people
who are either mentally unstable or
definitely on drugs or alcohol
they just able to set up camp everywhere
so you have these systems for shanty
towns yeah I don't think that's the
solution the solution is shelters some
other what but shelters it so because
they're finding diseases like oh like
bubonic plague and happiness and [ __ ]
[ __ ] that yeah I don't want to look at
it you know there's a way to desert
there's a way to deal with this and it's
not with these liberal policies that
Gavin Newsom and all those [ __ ] guys
in San Francisco they're so [ __ ] lame
and they don't have to live with it all
the politicians that are there and all
the tea councils they live they don't
they don't have to deal with that [ __ ] I
don't mind a little homeless little bum
but when some hobos especially in Venice
get that the Venice you know but when
there's just droves of this shit's out
of control bro and it's drugs alcohol
mental illness is a huge one if you're
in LA though they're violent so that's
why I'm even more like concern because
they'll punch people randomly well you
got away you got to wait until they do
something and then you know but anytime
you have that much riffraff they want to
get as in though they're getting high in
their [ __ ] tents they have set up if
you just come by to Venice oh yeah
that's its yeah also good enough watch
them yeah [ __ ] that that's your answer
so just keep them there okay cool
now you know they suck and can some are
just lazy let's be real with ups went
[ __ ] it yeah drugs and street life man
yep this is a current event no so
politically incorrect but I don't give a
[ __ ] what what else you guys got show
you guys that's not it oh here it is
okay so a prisoner in Iowa back in 2015
suffered a seizure which then led him to
being in a hospital when he was in the
hospital his brother was called and his
brother said if anything happens to my
brother do not resuscitate him the
doctor decided to ignore the brothers
wishes and resuscitated the prisoner the
prisoner then was revived but he was
technically dead for a couple of minutes
and he says that his life term should be
should have been certain point fair
point he's been trying to appeal it ever
since saying that if that doctor had
listened to his brother and dinner
resuscitate him then his sentence would
be over but since he resuscitated who
did his brother a power of attorney yes
oh wow Wow you know the man with the
handle of an axe in 1990
[Music]
that's what all the judges have said
they've all denied his case to try to
have his life sentence yeah I need to
know exactly what what his crime was
because all I know is he killed a guy
with an axe without without the handle
of an axe do we do know the guy up he
hit it hit him with the handle of him do
we know what he did though was it like
yeah he killed a man yeah I know but was
it in his house was it a passion crime
like what's going on there not sure it
did not there not let him out for a
reason though you know he's a legit
point though I did I'd be dead if you
[ __ ] in it I say free him III know I
knew the details on his 66 with with
kidney stones let him out yeah I would
you see what they did that one guy they
let this guy who was a murderer out the
day got out you know what he did oh he
killed a bunch of murderous a Mad Dog
they do Mad Dog killer he's like I am
fully rehabilitated I feel good and they
just murdered the next so that guy that
guy doesn't look like he's gonna it's
really hard to find when you
find anywhere to live when your um when
you have a record like that you can't
find a place to live
yeah so they want to go back in mm-hmm
oh it was oh this is this is his case
that's what it quick to but I went to
just a random page but when you go to it
let's see that they had details on what
he did he looks like a murder
Jesus Christ pawns you know where's that
scroll out was up there here yeah but
then I clicked on murder and he just
went to the random page killing a woman
no killing no man hand-woven axe 1996
life without parole that me that means
some pretty gnarly [ __ ] yeah I just
killed a gay
it doesn't really say what its murder
was life-without-parole that again
unless they've done some [ __ ] must have
killed innocent person maybe yeah you
can't let you out dude maybe I'm a
doctor really [ __ ] him though man oh
here we are yet I don't think we're in
figured up witnesses stated that she
Charlie with a woman oh it looks like it
was that a traffic dispute oh the man no
Schreiber Seann get the first degree
Americans barely sure usually along with
ax to club hair together - yeah it
doesn't say yeah that sucks traffic we
don't know can't have ID on the street
though hmm
what else already so there was a shirt
that got tweeted out on Amazon where
it's a little girl and I think somebody
edited a text over there selling a shirt
that says daddy's little [ __ ] and this
is the photo that was being sold they
were selling it in kid sizes and in the
description they said it was good for
like birthday parties
what was it please don't just Photoshop
it or did this was on Amazon so it was a
third party seller who posted this photo
up selling this child sized shirts and
daddy's little [ __ ] somebody found this
put it on Twitter and wanted to make
sure that went viral so Amazon would
take it there was an article there's an
article about how in on the web is so
hard to enforce child pornography 45
million images alone they've already
confiscated 45 million videos and images
it's so crazy and a lot of times it's
the kids own parents that's awful with
another man these [ __ ] people man I
would shoot him in the [ __ ] head yeah
but yeah this on Amazon the thing about
[ __ ] they sell they can't exactly it's
so hard to keep and also with the clouds
they're so encrypted and so you're
asking tech companies to go into
someones
cloud it's almost impossible to do its
also they can't do it because now
they're just gonna go to a place that
ensures your security what's interesting
to me about that is that law enforcement
actually can't go into your cloud and
even when they do the company itself
only looks at images they don't look at
video ok cuz there's just too much of it
and also it's it violates your privacy
so if Apple goes into my cloud and looks
at all my [ __ ] that's a violation of
privacy so it's just a [ __ ] major
problem and there are evil people out
there do it deal in this [ __ ] yes so the
third-party retailer put this up in June
so it's been up since June for $18 and
in their description it says that it's
suitable to wear at a birthday party
baby shower baptism stroller etosha
strolls it's a stupid [ __ ] this is
trolling but they took it down but yeah
they took it down I'm not sure if they
took down the third-party sellers page
altogether but they took down B shirt
Jesus Christ yeah PeopleSoft yep people
sock with us yep well in some lighter
news a comedian went on to Germany's Got
Talent and her act is that she drew a
dog on her butt cheeks and made it eat
hot dogs
I'd like to watch this you do because I
didn't find it fantastic Oh
wonder if she's she's probably stable um
already that's crazy well this goes on
for a while this is her whole act yes
and then it gets to a point where she
pulls out some hot dogs and makes the
dog eat the hot dogs here
just working with her [ __ ] there's
very that is cru greatest thing I've
ever seen why she's all air he can't do
that [ __ ] she open for me yeah oh my god
I'm not following that their girl only
dude only in [ __ ] Germany would they
hear something like that I mean she
wouldn't yeah but yeah that was for a
whole Act
Wow hopefully she wins it hopefully she
wins at all what would you do for the
next like round though I think I don't
know where you go from that assumed they
close the show out with that and just
like alright well that's our time yeah
you don't go anywhere from there I mean
you bop its bottom in the [ __ ]
Mondays it'd be flame she had like a
blast hot dog she was hot as [ __ ] and a
blonde
that's a defended your viral she kinda
adds like that weird flat German s it's
a flat German s a flat German older a
flat Jerry I thought flat germ old lady
older lady a flat germ yeah what else
you got let's do this hi this is a not
super current but it's very heartwarming
this little kid that replaced the kind
of all this yeah how dorable was that
good girl dude it's a little kid boy
good boy it's a little old kind of a
little older what I mean it's so
heartwarming yeah I mean I just his
worry he's like oh no those are little
girls approaching I found out they're
probably family members off so yeah oh
you just realize it's not I found out oh
it was in the beginning I thought it was
just some random people it was even
cuter I [ __ ] love Halloween but kids
get so excited yeah my son was like I'm
tired man back let's go back my son's
got a shelf life on [ __ ] he's like man
let's go back I'm like come on how many
houses are we gonna head home really um
he's over it then and my daughter you
can get my daughter like all the candy
in the world are like vanilla
say what she'll be like awesome yeah and
she'll drink a 3 quart a quarter sweet
tooth kids she'll be like I'm done it's
built in moderation my son give it all
ya all right next one
yeah all right this happened at another
Popeyes god damn this was pretty crazy
so I guess this woman and the white hair
apparently had laughing apparently she
called him the N word
I guess they charged her this is a
legend Tom pies
I probably allegedly charged her twice
for her order so that she complained
about it call me n-word and then he
according to the witnesses he called
that woman and ugly broke down cracker
hell yeah and then vile instance to hell
yeah so this is with them arguing
beforehand there's not much to this
video but the g-gonna racism we don't
have a good yeah this is him taking her
outside
oh he dragged her outside watch you'll
see how does none of those other guys
help this lady out I don't I mean I'm
sure they're just shot oldest that lady
she looks very old
you just slammed her and land her head
like her whole side so I mean that was a
hardcore slam that's so that's I mean
attempted murder for that so that is
soon I've got eyes firing them but you
never jump well now you can't do that so
you got to be fun well that's that's
you're in trouble a woman can't be a
woman up in slam run around assaults
enjoy that
I can't believe so wait did he pick her
up and carry outside their own so she
was walking away then he then he falters
receiving slander to see that he's
leaving give me a replay attacks leave
bucket DDT this dude did to this old
lady so she's like he grabbed her right
there wait who's punching her I know
he's punching her yeah that rewinding a
woman oh yeah yeah right yeah the woman
oh that's such a hard
the mesh thumb dude was that worth that
well he's in deep trouble he's in big
trouble dude it's hard for a DA he's
gonna go you followed her outside
grabbed her picked her up umbrella
another woman who was hitting her the
other one hitters [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah
they're both [ __ ] that's that's I
don't give a [ __ ] what somebody calls
you you just can't do that and they're
walking away and they're an old lady and
your employee of the store good luck
thief good luck [ __ ] this J got it
Popeyes yesterday when should the sent
me pictures yeah he's he's all about it
or he sayings is the best sandwich he's
ever had in his life
Mad Men chick-fil-a he says the best
sandwich he's ever had in his life he's
ever had how long razor that's why I
went wait to come LM Beach Alan Rice he
goes I don't need help okay
you said he goes I'm telling it's read
it cuts you guys getting a fight oh my
god
I hear me I don't get I don't mean I
need to try I don't know where I'm gonna
try it but I heard you can get off post
mates or there's there's a delivery
service can do it's $300 okay they wait
in line for you know feeds me $300 for
how long right no Helen raises different
Popeyes oh Jesus Christ
Popeyes is doing something with that
chicken they're doing something with
that chicken sandwich yes [ __ ] just
laying on her face yeah you just got
away couple more weeks until it dies
down because the chicken sandwich is
here to stay is that what they say yeah
so it's gonna be on the permanent menu
now there's no reason if we do it right
but ignorance is alive and well in
Tennessee and [ __ ] where was this a
Popeye's Chicken Tennessee yeah
Tennessee but I mean it does make you
hungry when you see it everywhere
it makes you want to eat it so it's and
Jay won't shut the [ __ ] up about it if
it's that good it goes got two of them
the best sandwich ever had my life no
wait dude I'm tell you how and raises
better did you get the regular or the
spicy one people are seeing the spicy
one is the good one I think spice has to
be spicy right it even sent me a picture
doesn't look great compared to Howland
Ray's don't look like [ __ ]
Palmer he looks good in persons here
like it looks like just like a beautiful
picture first I was so hot though let me
know I didn't
I took 17 miles why you did that
Oh bro my [ __ ] was like what the [ __ ]
about what his was hot yeah there's even
a hotter one
yeah there's extra hot and then howling
right my my my I feel like we should get
a haiku press to see how getting you
guys like the wings and then you guys
bite out of your [ __ ] your [ __ ]
they have like you can't die chicken
I'll be close to it be close to a toilet
I wanted to move my mouth as well you're
gonna be you're gonna be pulling
contracts nice I'll get I'll get mild so
you got hot burn baby burn
I got medium delicious was it too hot no
it's not perfect
I'd say it's perfect because medium has
a habanero and then when you get too hot
there's scorpion peppers and ghost
peppers in it
that's crazy bro white no bro that ain't
extra hot and then howlin mm-hmm howling
can't touch this ten plus plus
I just want to let's split a howling
it's it's up it's it's trouble dude
it struck out how big of a house is up
for you to get howling race uh they've
been pretty cool I just email them and
they prepare it I come right before the
thing fire it back up I feel like I want
it hot you want howling though yeah yeah
what I want to do is I want to get to
medium about diff Reisner yes
I think the first you're better when
you're when you're there then I like
cold fries too though I'd like to do is
get two mediums right that's gonna be my
mail and then that will get one howling
you were sick last time we had to you're
very sick I almost threw up I didn't
tell you this I was gonna [ __ ] my fate
the hot it was so hot I hate that and I
only I only ate half of it and I was
like because I thought about my poo
place my own I thought about my [ __ ]
room and I was like I'm and then I got
nauseous after I ate it I was like I
don't feel good
that halon's gonna [ __ ] in fact I'm
just I'm just now recupera I'm still on
the mend
yeah I really want to try howling got it
hot with that hot well how many people
order howling I don't know I feel like
people don't order howling just to eat a
chicken sandwich they do it for the
challenge yeah we're doing I mean I
would do how long
if you're not gonna reset in half just
and we'll eat it on there and see how it
goes
is that hot wings isn't that what that
is BAE hot ones hot ones yeah mmm hot
ones will they do different sauces
there's actually a video of red band
eating the howlin on YouTube
Oh they say it's hot yeah but I think he
eats it what they like how [ __ ] hot
was the howling yeah but everyone's
different though man I knew all right
with spice
I do all right with spice but that hot
was hot no no it's not the morning yeah
like that yeah I like what it's so spicy
I can enjoy my food now I was like my
mouth was I was like talking to your
eyes water when you breathe in yeah it's
like RJ's friend Buster he'll get ty hot
stuff and you'll see him eating the
noodles and you'll see beads of sweat
like what are you doing but that's what
he likes
I guess so yeah I think we go we get
yeah I think I've medium for the squad
and to outlet Hillary Clinton said that
she's kept herself away throughout the
campaign in 2008 by eating a lot of hot
pepper peppers I said how do you stay
she cuz I eat I eat hot peppers
interesting huh I remember one time my
buddy goes I'm gonna make you a robbery
toe I was like that's what I was so into
food I got into all the robbing and he
took two habanero peppers fresh ones
chopped them up put sunflower seeds and
[ __ ] avocado and and wrapped it in
there like I made a raw burrito and then
wrapped it in a [ __ ]
cabbage leaf and I ate it and I guess
suck you couldn't feel my mouth no cuz
you don't want that near your dick
couldn't feel my mouth Emily v8 and when
you cut habanero peppers you touch it
and you take a pee enjoy that on your
dick enjoy that so he made you a salad
he made me a me just your boy did you
wrap it in the [ __ ] yes [ __ ] but
I was like this is so good for you
meanwhile yes yet James problem this
happened recently American Airlines
plane slides off the runway at O'Hare in
Chicago and it's because it was all iced
out check it out is on the landing
August
it is icing yeah that'd be scariest for
[ __ ] landing and taking off right now
all right it's going sideways right now
that's Chicago so everyone safe no
injuries but look the wings on the
ground
[Music]
that's Monday morning that's a that's
Chicago right now well right yeah right
now there's a big cold front over
everywhere except right here not here
here we go I'll take fires there was
just a fire at Warner Bros on Saturday
at Hollywood Hills yeah I always forget
how Wonder Broz Oh cuz that's that's no
that's Denver Denver sunny though not
night now Denver's Collbran Oh kid
Denver's called I murderer but here I
weren't driving your house in Denver I
hadn't driven in snow in a long time yes
and I was driving to his house and I'm
not kidding I was sliding I was [ __ ]
sliding it was it was nothing
I was like I got a kid I got a drive
five miles an hour to keep that [ __ ]
keeps no bro I abide by some I got see I
was like it was Austin you oh my god
you're driving like this can't control
your car dude sliding good news
I don't think I you don't you don't want
move back to Denver and you can suck my
son eat and a [ __ ] my son Esai and my
dick fire oh yeah we got fire saying it
was bad was bad there's nowhere safe in
California for fires yeah oh I'm gonna
move to the hills I moved to Hollywood I
move nowhere safer everywhere there's
but everybody can get lit up here yeah
everybody get set on fire yeah the hills
Warner Bros had to shut down all good
baby price you pay to live here you know
yeah I just got nervous thinking about
sliding and getting hit by oh dude that
that's growing up with that [ __ ] man I'm
nervous I just started biting my nails I
in dressing like puffy like [ __ ] like
the Michelin Man did [ __ ] off yeah cover
your face is super cold out why people
up you dying bitter cold
I remember New England needs football in
the snow that's one though isn't it no
no your hands breaking I actually think
your mask is frozen oh I would never
move anywhere with the snow that's why I
can't live in New York I can't live in
Boston now I have to stay here freezing
and in New England you you would get so
it would be get so cold that your hair
would freeze the nostrils the mucus in
your nostrils would freeze Chicago last
year my girls general is out there they
took a hot
hot coffee yeah threw it in there froze
before it hit the ground there you go
what yeah no thanks yeah that's that
kind of cold I know so well it burns
it's so head bronze like it's just not
fun now
I don't like you know bundled up the
snows outside you can die in it right
quick and it's gonna be a painful death
it feels like fire I kind of called us
together
you wanna know just one more quick one
sure this is just Kanye saying he's
gonna run for president and then his
reaction after he says it which I know
sue was not joking and you'll see how
he's not joking here legit when I run
for president 2024
you're gonna definitely know which I
laughing that yeah I see I knew sliders
terrible here's the problem with Kanye
he's on this he's off his meds right has
legit mental sickness which makes him
also very creative but also there comes
pros and cons the cons would be this
[ __ ] biz also just rollin he just
thought that's what he's professional
controller too but the other thing about
him is he's so religious now have you
yes Kim and and everyone on his staff to
live celibate not to have sex yeah he's
like doing all this crazy stuff now it's
such a bummer do you think he's also
doing that kind of let role I think it's
it's a weird thing I hope it's hard to
hope I'm a big Kanye fan of some of his
stuff and then I'll see a lot of stuff
I'm just like oh god dude
a new album is trash I think like any
else when somebody steps out of their
area of expertise stick to music well
here's the problem though be is a trump
one so now everyone's like oh yeah
anybody can wear that's right that's
right
but Trump and hey here's the thing
they're right yeah but Trump's also have
a businessman who spent a lot of time in
politics being a businessman so never
but never yeah
I'm not it's not well definitely not a
national politician yeah
politician use a reality really the
biggest thing he's ever done reality
stuff yeah yeah that was it so you get
you just get out okay
why not me yeah yeah yeah it's crazy i I
do think that Trump had more experience
with trade and with China and dealing
with this there's a difference there he
comes at it from a but you know look
Kanye West is a businessman too isn't he
you know he's worth billion dollars
worth a billion dollars
close to it he's rich man in music now
just I think he surpassed jay-z and or
he's on pace of hata jay-z and trash I
don't like it cause it's so religious
okay he is a very unique I would I think
the people running for president when
you had suffered mental illness and when
you're that unstable is pretty scary
I think trials for the unstable too
though I would say Narciso Trump's
consistent in that you you can kind of
predict what he's gonna do if you attack
him you know right back again this is
just rolling from Connie yeah a cute
name it would never in a million years
of wind right be that you thought the
amount of stress and what comes with
being the president he's no fun you
think you're me it'll do this music can
do this stuff be President you have any
idea what the entails you know the
exhaustion and the stretch but on your
family the life is over now this jet
sent me already talking about yeah let
me president but there is ego there
right so if he becomes president just
told them yeah the egos your feed an ego
I'm a doctor Trump who has the biggest
of you in the world if I do not do this
day off what else you get you want
another one are you good mmm doesn't
good they're all kind of just like
whatever I guess yeah this was I found
this okay the headline makes it look
like it's worse but it's saying that he
was booed on stage I saw this too why at
flog no but they didn't want to see him
they would they wanted to see the other
act but it's Drake doesn't everybody
love [ __ ] Drake so they were looking
for Frank Ocean I guess if you're a
Franco
fan maybe it's not as drakey as you
thought you don't like drink as much I
mean worst part is yours alright man
I'll keep gone if you just give me a
little love and they keep booing up it's
so [ __ ] up I didn't really hear the
boos oh it's just sounding like they
weren't super stoked but I saw one words
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there see he gets off here's I'll keep
going if you guys want to they start
blowing about right [ __ ] it's all
love I'm out man
well he handled it really well too
though he said that I is a I think when
I listen to Kanye West I don't know
music you know I'm older I get it cuz
Kanye West has got some amazing songs
and and Connie was kind of guys the more
you hear him like when he collabs with
jay-z and just his album I have
everything he's ever written
he's [ __ ] I get it he's so innovative
have you heard his new one I haven't but
I'm saying is I get the Kanye I get what
kinase Kanye I've listened to Drake and
I've tried to give him a fair shake I
think he's a lightweight I think he's a
pop lightweight am I wrong about that
I'm not saying I'm not talking about
town either
I just think he's I think they're a
couple things going on one he's a
lightweight stew he's not really he
doesn't really talk that way like he's
got that hip-hop kind of thing going on
but he's Canadian he grew up around I
think his mom was white so I mean
there's a thing is mom's what he doesn't
actually mom is Jewish he doesn't act
hard though be know something about his
music that doesn't feel very authentic
and he feels very popular
he feels poppy you say it's not like
support now he's not like have you heard
his mixtapes no those are the ones that
he got famous off of and that was more
of his audience was a lot of girls he
made music for girls who were strippers
but till he tells them like you're
you're beautiful there's nothing wrong
with you okay he is like sanely huge hip
he's like a lady that's not what I'm
talking about so just because you have
huge stars Taylor Swift mm-hmm so so
she's big as eyes in the world
yeah but that doesn't mean the Taylor
Swift is deep I know you're saying yes
no he's not like a lyric sis yeah yeah
so so sometimes when you get it kinda
like Daddy yeah Kendra yeah that's
that's yeah that's what you say
something legit about Kendrick Lamar
there's something with chit about Kanye
West like like you you there's a depth
to them that's a gravitas like even with
Kanye West's in like his mental illness
and stuff it makes sense cuz he's got
he's such an artistic innovator
well generalization right mmm-hmm
so so so I don't think of that as I
don't and I think sometimes audiences
see through that in an example like this
I don't know what this audience was I
don't think that's right I think Drake
it's a tunnel like he's literally the
biggest musician in the world he hits a
ton of love I think here they were
expecting Franco Franco she's very he's
like R&B and like deep too yeah and it's
very rare that you see Frank Ocean
perform ever yeah so it's I think it's
one of the things where if you came to
watch Franco like [ __ ] yeah cuz it was
deep Frank Ocean yeah I get it I'm not
surprised by that as I guess what I'm
saying I'm not surprised playing I
doubted I was like weird I listened
off'ring I think young people it's weird
you'd boo anybody though I mean yes is
Drake that's more entertainment out of
his day to come there and like and you
know maybe Frank was next yeah the Bowie
guy is so strange to me yeah so see
Drake can't flog no I heard about it
yesterday she was in LA right was it
somewhere in oh yeah usually when they
have their festival here in LA it
happens in South Central that'll [ __ ]
with you know who your own Mountain
leave it there yeah so yet it's uh it's
guys who cross over the mainstream a lot
of these like Indies and people hate ya
that'll [ __ ] with you a little bit
Dodger Stadium there it is
so it's safe for a handful of guys who
have crossover the mainstream - baby 21
savage juice world yg etc the majority
the acts cater a bit of a more indie
listener ditto for Frank Ocean who's the
king of the whole genre right now
meanwhile Drake is mainstream as they
get so that make sense the
anti-mainstream yeah yeah yeah make
sense if you come to these pretty
mainstream but usually they be excited
though anyways yeah they would be like
well Drake
I know you care I mean getting booed
offstage is pretty tough man that said
that's a rough one that's like yes that
doesn't feel good I don't care who you
are
here's very cool about it too though
yeah it'll [ __ ] with your head though oh
yeah I'm sure you went back like what
yeah weird worries you it worries you
everybody I don't care who you are
everybody cuz this might be it for me
yeah you always feel that way if you
don't feel that way as an artist in
there then you're not probably not of
course you you always are terrified of
losing your relevance you're always
trying to stay relevant you're always
trying to be original just Tyler the
Creator show right so it's not a Drake
fanbase you know another thing - it's
like going you know if you expecting to
see like a comedy movie and horse shows
up like what laughter [ __ ] that's true
that's true I think that's why these I'm
not sure your entire creators fan base
is young Willow Smith is there - they're
there to see something and young people
want the newest cutting trend if you
give them you know I remember what I
remember I [ __ ] remember so well
being 27 on the new comedy scene MADtv
was the hottest most irreverent show and
I was in the original [ __ ] cast I
didn't know on there and you know what
the most you know what you know
everybody's favorite thing to do was I'm
talking about really good comics good
comments the comics of tomorrow that I
was around what was their favorite who
was their favorite person to bash Jim
Carrey Jim Carrey and I was like I'm
never going Jim Carrey's a [ __ ]
genius you none of you [ __ ] can
touch Jim Carrey but it's it was like
one joke was like Jim Carrey or slow
dental surgery with no novocaine
I was like oh really well here's a but
that was the trendy thing to do but why
are you guys hating on Jim Carrey cuz
he's he'll
because he's also he's killing he was
also I'm are also going if he was in
doing well and people don't like him you
wouldn't hate on oh yeah and also no but
Jim Beam or isn't it Jim Carrey I don't
give a [ __ ]
I've been doing comedy for I don't know
how long you don't get better than that
[ __ ] his ability to do
characters his ability to act his
ability to be hilarious you know what he
would do to you comedy-wise view and
when he was doing stand-up that
shouldn't you still do he's a [ __ ]
beast in every way and they just loved
him and I was like shut up
I remember that I read those first time
I went oh I get it okay okay well also
Drake to his knees pretty high energy
like I wonder if this crowd with a booed
Travis Scott - I don't think he's as
mainstream as right no he just barely
got the man-traps cuts I think I think
his affiliates went Kim card I mean with
Kelly I think I think he got it he
probably gotten booed but see I don't
really follow rap or hip-hop I got so
mainstream but I know he's huge though
was it you just have a Scott
I barely started hearing about him like
recently I think that Peter when they
think of Drake imagery from Canada those
those guys I'm like he's not hard he's
not budging I don't think it's that cuz
Tyler craves not hard willow submit that
hard Frank Ocean definitely ain't hard
this is an indie thing yeah it's not
about the gangster raps dead Kanye
killed gangster oh it's been gone
forever so it's not that their thing is
is that it's like you know they're just
there to enjoy the music and like it's
not a hype crowd and Drake's like come
on like I just a different my son wanted
to hear rap he either wants hard rock or
rap and so I put on the rap station I'm
streaming on my Tesla had the streaming
thing hey ruff we mean streaming you
mean serious I know I haven't like
Pandora something like whatever Tesla
set you up with but I had turned off my
year old because I mean it's it's it's
ass and [ __ ] what did you think it okay
no I'm pretty - boy you to bring extra
me like I'm at my
listen to this [ __ ] the shooters and
word this name with that and getting but
[ __ ] this and I say around I'm like
[ __ ] guys can we talk about anything
else
[ __ ] you you could blame the new Kanye I
don't think there's any custom out there
does the Lord right now all right
all right guys good good pop them in the
[ __ ] Monday I wanna thank you guys
got popped in the [ __ ] so got pop in
the [ __ ] I'm gonna go do some acting
now juice American dude I'm of tour
starts this week man Dallas Thursday
Friday Saturday I'm told to go the pecan
lounge gone laugh for the barbecue
supposed to be the best part you in
Dallas what's the last time it's pretty
taste like I'd like a different place
but I won't go there so I'm doubt this
Thursday Friday Saturday next week
Thursday Friday Saturday in Salt Lake
City Utah wise guys when our favorite
clubs be and the Pasadena Brian I keep
asking if they dude are you around I'm
I'm gonna come by on the 27th at
Thanksgiving the day before yeah it is
before the day before yeah yeah
stay before ok yeah no I think I'm
around yeah I'm coming I'm coming
alright ice house with me and Kalyn and
some other friends
that's one night only we just announced
that ice house Pasadena sha'ban friends
Pasadena that's the night before
Thanksgiving the 27th and then Ken City
December 6 through the 7th tickets at f
@k calm Oh in Atlantic City and La Jolla
just went on sale in Exedy New Jersey
the giant casino there Atlantic City's
December 14th La Jolla San Diego
basically December 19th through 21st The
Comedy Store get your tickets come fat K
Tom and I'll be at the Wilbur New Year's
Eve I'm doing the Wilbur New Year's Eve
just announced usually sided yeah so
come on down to the Wilbur New Year's
Eve in Boston I'm excited oh yeah
Brandon yo Sasha oh this is the finally
kid we're out